now to Nashville in the community
struggling after that deadly school
shooting hundreds of people came
together last night for a Citywide vigil
honoring the three School workers and
three nine-year-old children who were
killed earlier in the day First Lady Joe
Biden visited the memorial outside of
Covenant School where the violence
unfolded Jenna shamlin has more from
Nashville
[Music]
Tennessee Nashville turned to what it's
best known for music
[Music]
sir
after unfathomable tragedy
I'm crying we Ed with Nashville
city leaders family
Gathering Wednesday to mourn the six
lives lost Nashville has had its worst
today our heart is broken our city
United
as we mourn together and recognize the
officers who ran toward the gunfire to
stop the shooter we are grateful to the
team of officers
who rushed into that school building
without hesitation just before the vigil
Dr Biden visited the memorial outside
the Covenant School pausing it each
victim's photo before leaving flowers
the growing tribute has become a place
of comfort you can feel the sadness in
in the city right now it's it's really
overwhelming we're hurting right now
pretty badly city council member Russ
pulley represents covenant's District he
says staff members died trying to
protect the kids Catherine Koontz heard
the shots into the zoom call immediately
and abruptly left that meeting and left
her office police officers found kuntz's
body just outside her office would it
surprise you
to learn that she had gone out and
confronted an active shooter oh no I
would absolutely expect that from
Catherine Coons and principles that's
what Educators and administrators do
they protect their children
and this morning we're learning more
about some of the other victims like
nine-year-old Hallie Scruggs her aunt
posting on Facebook that she was
incredibly smart and had a love for life
that kept her smiling
heartbreaking stuff Gail
and another reminder she was nine years
old those it's those stories that get
you every time thank you Janet thank you
very much